Kris Jenner is living her best life with
yachts diamonds and no Rob drama
[Applause]
the reality TV star is in San Tropez
enjoying a romantic getaway with her
boyfriend Cory gamble on Tuesday the
famous momager was photographed enjoying
a dinner date with her man sporting this
white lace dress and a massive rock on
her ring finger how am I gonna explain
this rumors quickly escalated that Cory
popped the question
when Chris's daughter Khloe Kardashian
shared the pic on Instagram with the
caption you being happy makes us happy
cheers to the Queen you deserve to love
your life but a source close to the
family matriarch tells et the two aren't
engaged on Wednesday the family's makeup
artist Joyce Benelli shared this pic of
the 61 year old striking a very dramatic
pose on a yacht rocking a mini dress
with a whole lot of bling and on
Thursday Chris looked ageless in a black
bikini and black cover up as she headed
to lunch while Chris is living the good
life in France and I'll do it this more
than tired her son Rob Kardashian is
facing a legal battle back at home with
ex blac Chyna I would like to first and
foremost thank the judge for granting me
this restraining order to protect me on
Monday a judge granted Chyna a temporary
restraining order against Rob which
restricts him from posting about her on
social media
[Music]
you
[Music]